there are four types of analytics
descriptive analytics diagnostic
analytics
predictive analytics and prescriptive
the more complex an analysis is the more
value it brings
descriptive analytics answers the
question of what happened
for instance a healthcare provider will
learn how many patients were
hospitalized last month
a retailer the average weekly sales
volume a manufacturer
a rate of the products returned for a
past month etc
descriptive analytics juggles raw data
from multiple data sources to give
valuable insights into the past however
these findings simply signal that
something is wrong or right
without explaining why for this reason
highly data-driven companies do not
content themselves with descriptive
analytics only
and prefer combining it with other types
of data analytics
diagnostic analytics at this stage
historical data can be measured against
other data to answer the question of why
something happened
thanks to diagnostic analytics there is
a possibility to drill down
to find out dependencies and to identify
patterns companies go for diagnostic
analytics
as it gives in-depth insights into a
particular problem
for example in the healthcare industry
analysis of customer segmentation
coupled with several filters applied
such as diagnosis and prescribed
medications
allowed measuring the risk of
hospitalization
predictive analytics tells what is
likely to happen
it uses the findings of descriptive and
diagnostic analytics to detect
tendencies
clusters and exceptions and to predict
future trends
which makes it a valuable tool for
forecasting
despite numerous advantages that
predictive analytics brings
it is essential to understand that
forecasting is just an estimate
the accuracy of which highly depends on
data quality and stability of the
situation
so it requires a careful treatment and
continuous optimization
thanks to predictive analytics and the
proactive approach it enables
a telecom company for instance can
identify the subscribers who are most
likely to reduce their spend
and trigger targeted marketing
activities to remediate
a management team can weigh the risks of
investing in their company's expansion
based on cash flow analysis and
forecasting
prescriptive analytics the purpose of
prescriptive analytics is to literally
prescribe what action to take to
eliminate a future problem or take full
advantage of a promising trend
this state-of-the-art type of data
analytics requires not only historical
data
but also external information due to the
nature of statistical algorithms
besides prescriptive analytics uses
sophisticated tools and technologies
like machine learning business rules and
algorithms
which makes it sophisticated to
implement and manage
that is why before deciding to adopt
prescriptive analytics
a company should compare required
efforts versus an expected added value
what types of data analytics do
companies choose
for the global data and analytics survey
big decisions
pwc asked more than 2 000 executives to
choose a category that describes their
company's decision-making process
best further c-suite was questioned with
what type of analytics they rely on most
the results were the following
descriptive analytics dominates in the
rarely data-driven decision-making
category
58 diagnostic analytics tops the list in
the somewhat data-driven category
34 while it is closely followed by
descriptive analytics
29 and prescriptive analytics 28
predictive analytics 36 percent leads in
the highly data driven category
this survey proves that at different
stages of a company's development
there appears a need for one or the
other type of analytics
in fact the companies that strive for
informed decision making
find descriptive analytics insufficient
and add up diagnostics analytics or even
go as far as predictive one
the same survey reveals another trend
executives want decision making to be
faster and more sophisticated
this means that more businesses will
strive to gradually enlarge the share of
predictive analytics
another survey of business intelligence
trends for 2017
carried by barc proves this hypothesis
two thousand eight hundred executives
confirmed the growing importance of
predictive analytics and data mining
in summary with various types of
analytics
companies are free to choose how deep
they need to dive in data analysis to
satisfy their business needs best
while descriptive and diagnostic
analytics offers a reactive approach
predictive and prescriptive analytics
makes users proactive
meanwhile current trends show that more
and more companies come to the situation
when they need advanced data analysis
and choose to adopt it